love it or loathe it there's no denying
that five nights at freddy's or fnaf is
a global sensation but how did this
indie game about animatronic animals get
so many sequels books fan theories and
even a movie this is the history of five
nights at freddy's
in 2013 indie developer scott cawthon
released a mobile game called chipper
and sons lumber company where players
would control a small beaver named tyke
as he sets out into beaver forest to do
favors for other animals and gathers
lumber for his dad chipper despite its
cutesy appearance it had a sort of
horrifying look about it
notable critics such as jim stephanie
sterling called the characters faces
ghastly and mentioned that they had a
creepy animatronic vibe to them what in
the name of jesus saint mark
initially deterred even going so far as
to remove chipper from steam's green
light page corthan decided to turn his
lemons into lemonade and make something
much scarier
gotham originally set up a kickstarter
to help fund the game but ended up
cancelling it after around six months of
working on the game alone in early june
2014 he released a trailer for his new
title five nights at freddy's
the premise of the game was simple
players would act as the night time
security guard at freddy fazbear's pizza
watching over the joints famed and
beloved animatronics by a security
camera each night you're alone save for
the animatronics and calls from phoneguy
an ex-employee who leaves you messages
at the start of each shift to tell you
how to play the game and to reveal some
law
there's nothing to worry about
sounds simple enough but the
animatronics including freddy fazbear
bonnie chica and foxy have become
erratic unpredictable and even dangerous
if they find a human they'll kill them
by stuffing them into a costume they
need to be watched at night because in
1987
one of them bit somebody resulting in a
serious injury players follow them via
security cameras and can use their
limited amount of electricity to hit the
lights as well as lock the security
doors gotham revealed in an interview
that he deliberately wanted the game to
be mechanically simple so that anyone
could play it without needing to be able
to understand english to get to grips
with the tutorial dotted throughout the
game were references to much darker
dealings and events that happened at the
restaurant over the years like a man who
killed children at the establishment
five nights at freddy's was greenlit on
steam in august 2014 and eventually
released there and via desura for five
dollars it came to android and ios a
couple of months later its short length
and cheap price were attractive enough
but it was also perfect youtube let's
play fodder and that helped the game
blow up it was simple to understand
tense for both the viewer and the player
and generated huge over-the-top
reactions hey
[Music]
god this night is lasting forever
youtubers like markiplier jacksepticeye
and pewdiepie played it and got millions
of views helping the game go viral
youtube even revealed that five nights
at freddy's was the eighth most watched
game on the platform it even reviewed
relatively well we gave it an 8 out of
10 and it wasn't long before a sequel
was teased
when i say it wasn't long i wasn't
kidding the sequel was teased on
cortland's website less than a month
later and it was set to release in 2015.
weirdly though it was actually released
much earlier hitting steam on november
10th 2014. five nights at freddy's 2
took place at a different restaurant in
1987 and featured both the old and new
models of the animatronics from the
first game as well as some new additions
like the terrifying balloon boy and the
puppet the core gameplay was much the
same players would sit in the security
office and man the cameras watching for
the animatronics as they snuck around
the fazbear pizza joint but kauthan
added a few changes you couldn't lock
the doors like in the first game and you
could now repel some of the animatronics
using a mask or other specific items
like a music box or a torch
but the biggest change came with the
game's fail state sometimes instead of
seeing a game over screen players would
be greeted with a strange mini game
known as the death mini games in these
you'd be controlling one of the
animatronics as they give children cake
or
gifts occasionally a creepy purple man
can be seen killing children and it's
with these death minigames where the
fandom started to dig deep into the
game's lore to learn more about the
horrors that may have happened at freddy
fazbear's pizza over the years and who
was behind them towards the end of the
game it's implied that the person who
was bitten in 1987 was you and the place
was shut down for a while after with
another security guard fritz smith
taking over before being fired after one
day five nights at freddy's 2 received
criticism for being much harder than its
predecessor was but was still immensely
popular by seeding law and a general
feeling of unsettledness its fanbase was
growing and eager for the next
installment
[Music]
and again it really wasn't long before
it came out striking while the iron was
hot kauthan's website went offline in
december 2014. viewers were shown a
creepy image of an animatronic with the
tagline i am still here in january 2015
with the trailer and steam green light
page dropping at the end of the month
gotham trolled fans by announcing that
the game was cancelled after a hacker
had stolen it then linking to a modified
version of a game he'd previously made
called there is no pause button set 30
years after freddy fazbear's pizza
closed fnaf 3 takes place in a horror
attraction that depicts the urban
legends of the haunted pizza parlor
complete with props scavenged from the
restaurants including an animatronic
named springtrap your tools were fragile
this time so security cameras vent
control and speakers would break meaning
that you need to keep rebooting the
systems to keep springtrap at bay
springtrap is the only animatronic in
the game while freddy and the gang also
appear their phantom versions of
themselves providing jump scares aplenty
but they don't kill you instead they
just up the ante as springtrap gets
closer death minigames return and
actually hint at other minigames that
you can access from inside your office
there are multiple endings depending on
how many of the mini games you completed
in april 2015 it was revealed that
warner brothers had snapped up the
rights to make a five nights at freddy's
movie and a few big names were attached
including roy lee who had previously
produced the departed and the lego movie
as well as cat smith productions which
went on to produce the adaptation of
stephen king's it the movie was hit with
a number of delays before finally
landing at bloomhouse productions at one
point home alone director chris columbus
was attached to direct but his
involvement ended as of september 2021
the script is still being worked on last
time we heard from the project this
can't be very interesting like play
through sorry guys because
we have to hear
you
okay i heard thumped on something
five nights at freddy's 4 meanwhile
takes place in 1984 and in a radical
switch up for the franchise doesn't have
you monitoring security cameras in any
way it takes place inside a child's
bedroom and we learn through mini-games
that the child has an intense fear of
fazbear's pizza restaurant honestly who
can blame them unsurprisingly the game
has animatronics trying to kill you and
the only way to fend them off is by
shining a flashlight on them before
slamming a door in their face fnaf 4 got
middling reviews and it was billed as
the final chapter of the five nights at
freddy's original story naturally then
it was widely assumed to be the last
game in the franchise
psych five nights at freddy's sister
location was revealed in 2016 but its
release wasn't exactly straightforward
at one point some of the game's voice
cast had leaked and kauthen's website
claimed that it had been cancelled due
to those leaks however it turned out
that this was a post relating to the
events of the game's story gorthon also
took to the game's steam forums to
reveal that it had been delayed citing
that the game was too dark and that he
was unsure how it will affect people the
whole thing turned out to be a stunt
again and the game launched on october
7th
[Music]
to be fair to scott the plot was pretty
messed up it features animatronics
purposefully made to be child kidnapping
machines
which at one point kind of backfired and
killed their creator's daughter these
machines then merge their skeletons
together to make it kind of megazord
animatronic and escape by hiding in the
skin of your character the game tries to
balance out its grim story with an ai
character named handy who provides a bit
of levity but some reviewers found this
pretty jarring
[Music]
the next main line entry was decidedly
much more lighthearted
well for a while at least freddy
fazbear's pizzeria simulator is free and
is exactly what it sounds like a
business simulator you design pizzas and
serve them to happy kids eventually
making business decisions to expand and
keep your joint ahead of the game all
while attempting to stop any rogue
animatronics from doing what they do
best in this franchise with kauthan
evolving the fnair formula in multiple
ways it was only a matter of time before
the series came to vr to ensure maximum
jump scares okay so that's the okay so
how do can i can they [ __ ] off can they
leave
stop they'll leave
just
take the cup
take take your
[ __ ] garbage have a great old dandy
night
mean yeah okay [ __ ] you
oh no no no no no something's still
there
ah
help wanted developed by steel ball
studios is a mix of modes inspired by
the other games meaning you're not just
staring at the security monitors but in
vr admittedly though there is some of
that but other modes offered more
variety like fixing animatronics or
listening out for animatronics in the
dark and shining a torch to keep them
away help wanted was well received by
fans and critics alike with many
praising the variety of minigames and
the effectiveness of vr to make it
scarier which brings us to security
breach the latest mainstream fnaf game
once again developed by steel wool games
it's a direct sequel to help wanted a
young boy is locked in a freddy fazbear
shopping mall overnight and you guessed
it the place is packed with deadly
animatronics who are out to get him the
game was originally due to be released
in 2020 but was delayed due to the
pandemic to make up for the delay
quarton released a free beat-em-up game
called security breach fury's rage in
june 2021 kauthen retired from
public-facing video game development
claiming that he missed making games for
fun and for his kids he had been
embroiled in a political controversy
donating over forty thousand dollars to
republican politicians leading to
criticism from his fan base in
particular the lgbtq plus community who
were directly impacted by his actions
gorthen took to reddit to say he would
not apologize for the donations and that
he was simply trying to back the people
who would make a difference so there you
have it the history of the mainline five
nights at freddy's games for more deep
dives into your favorite franchises make
sure to like this video and subscribe to
gamespot thanks for watching
[Music]